and this [ __ ] mike busey invites
all veterans to his house this will have
like two or three hundred veterans at
his house and this jenny jizz [ __ ]
sucks them all off wow so if you're a
veteran and you live in central florida
and you want a [ __ ] on veterans day
all you gotta do is pull up to the
sausage castle and jenny jizz will serve
you in a room bro
it's like a room full of like 200 dudes
and this [ __ ] is just in the middle of
her just no she's in the middle just
serving everybody with [ __ ] [ __ ] all
over her [ __ ] face
oh my god you [ __ ] maniac oh dawg we
just been bigger than you
wait wait wait wait we're recording so
listen you up i was just talking about
veteran's day blow jobs at your house
yeah who was jimmy james the girl's
name's jenny jizz right
how many guys at one time mike
have you had over there on veterans day
that she sucked off
i mean we've had hundreds come over here
to celebrate the party
but
have she's sucked up in one party i
think the record's probably around like
30 35 40. it just came all at once like
as a part of a crew
well what happens is when we do it we
kind of like do it by like all right
who's had the most active years in
service if you're missing a leg or an
arm that bumps you up to the line so if
someone's amputated their amputee they
get up to the front
oh yeah purple heart that'll get you far
up and so [ __ ] yeah
it's like a [ __ ] draft a [ __ ]
draft dude mike man we've been bigging
you up you're the [ __ ] man dude
i'm over here i'm like yo i'm like
were talking about the first time i met
you was at a ritz show and that night he
stayed back and i went to your house i
was just telling him that's why i don't
and he would have been over here that's
what
exactly what i was saying about you bro
i was like yo mike
seems like this crazy guy he's very
eccentric he's all that but he
like i can't [ __ ] with you mike because
you're a maniac you'll get me in trouble
so i was so excited to hear what went
down
at the spot and this [ __ ] was talking
about [ __ ] jenny cheers jenny jess
dawg thank you for your contribution
mike i love you bro